die forschung findet im moment eher in
einer unglaublichen geschwindigkeit
staat aber trotzdem dauert sie halt
einfach insofern davon einfach nicht
müde werden immer wieder zu sagen wir
wissen es nicht genau
[Musik]
ich bin kein kopfschmerz ich bin
wissenschaftsjournalist ohne klavier
medizin studiert inzwischen arbeite ich
eigentlich fast nur noch für sein ich
bin der kontrollierten korrespondent in
deutschland für sie und schreibe vor
allem über infektionskrankheiten
konnte war eine riesige märkte haben
sich wirklich versucht die man wirklich
versucht da irgendwie nah an der
realität zu sagen genau das ist genau
das was ich spannend findet der film kam
2011 raus und hat damals schon extrem
viel vorhergesagt von der heutigen
situation mit corona ja ich hab das
überrascht weil der film eigentlich so
als film als ich meine ist ja fast wie
so eine große strecken wurden nicht viel
geredet wird oder so und auch die
charaktere sind nicht so vollkommen
ausgemalt ist lange her dass hingeguckt
habe aber ich weiß dass ich so dass das
szenario grundsätzlich fand ich ribéry l
ist jemand im zweifelsfall muss immer
unrealistisch würdest du nicht die
konventionen das dass das für uns ja wir
haben hier ist ausbruchs präsentieren
für den hong kong begrenzt zwei tagen
rund zehn verdachtsfälle
sie würden dasselbe protokollant wieder
manchmal saß das wird das integrierte
hin und wird aus dem turm untersucht
großteil der menschlichen erreger sind
jahr 2000 also gerade wenn irgendwo über
neue erreger reden in regel kommen die
irgendwie vom tier auf den menschen das
heißt die überspringen die artgrenze wir
wissen dass besonders in fledermäusen
und auch in nagetieren ist ein riesiges
reservoir gibt dann an verschiedenen
viren von denen manche wahrscheinlich in
der lage sind den menschen zu infizieren
und ein arme leute natürlich untersucht
so wo ist die biodiversität am höchsten
wo hat man am meisten kontakt zu diesen
tieren und so weiter und im grunde um
kommt so als ein hotspot immer wieder
diese region im süden chinas das ist das
ist eine der regionen von der wir wissen
dass da ein hohes risiko besteht dass da
die nächste pandemie herkommt das ist
kein zufall dass laster kamen dass jetzt
dieses virus dauer kann das auch so
viele untersuchungen gemacht wurden also
wir haben eine ganze menge waren
hinweise gehabt über die jahre dass das
passieren kann und haben herausgefunden
wie es die zu empfindungen und hirn
infiziert ich glaube die orientieren
sich dann tatsächlich so ein bisschen am
nipahviren ausbruch des virus
das waren schweinefarmen in indonesien
malaysia glaube ich die schweine fahrer
hatten auf ihren auf ihren farmen auch
feigen bäume gepflanzt und sein
zusätzliches einkommen zu haben
dann sind die fledermäuse gekommen haben
diese feigen angeknabbert und manche
davon auf den boden fallen lassen somit
teil speichel dran und das haben die
schweine gegessen die schweine haben
sich infiziert mit diesem virus von der
fledermaus dann hat sich das in schwei
ausgebreitet und darüber wurden dann die
die bauern infiziert das muss nicht
immer heißen das dann wirklich das virus
so verändert dass es muss jetzt nicht
sein dass da verschiedene teile von vom
erbgut von dem schweinevirus und einen
pfleger müssen wir uns zusammen kommen
aber es kann natürlich theoretisch
passieren häufigere variante ist dass
wir einfach ein virus haben das aus
welchem grund auch immer relativ gut
darin ist die spezies grenze zu
überspringen und dann überspringt das
entweder von der fledermaus direkt zum
menschen oder ich bin von der fledermaus
meinetwegen zum schwein und dann vom
schwein zum menschen
natürlich so dass wir mehr kontakt haben
mit
mit mit nutztieren und dass er eher
passieren kann wenn sich so ein virus
ausbreitet in der nutztiere population
das ist dann von da auf den auf den
menschen überspringen werden jetzt palm
wahrscheinlich erst mal abgeräumt symbol
für umweltzerstörung menschliche
eingriffe genau genau fledermäuse
fliegen aber bananen anja es ist genau
das niemals szenario also die fledermaus
lässt jetzt ein teil der frucht in den
schweinestall fallen
das schwein kommt beim kommt da irgendwo
in der küche an einem schönen restaurant
im casino genau und gwyneth paltrow dank
dem den kopf nochmal für das leckere
essen und macht ein foto mit ihm
übrigens ganz interessant ist weil das
natürlich in der bei der bei der
nachverfolgung von diesen von diesen
epidemien immer dann rolle spielt man
muss nämlich die kontaktpersonen
herausfinden wenn man jetzt jemanden hat
der positiv getestet wird dann möchte
man natürlich wissen mit wem hatte der
bisher kontakt umzusehen so bekennt er
sich infiziert haben
oder sie und wie wen könnte er oder sie
angesteckt haben deswegen spielt
natürlich auch dann zum beispiel diese
affäre oder so eine rolle
der kommt es dann richtig zu all diesen
diskussionen über datenschutz
privatsphäre und das ist genau das was
wir jetzt auch in deutschland
wahrscheinlich haben werden in den
nächsten wochen ist eine diskussion noch
mal darüber wie viel können wir
bewegungsdaten von menschen aus werten
über ihre telefone und so weiter um zu
sehen wo sie vielleicht waren einige
sachen die die chinesen relativ schnell
gemacht habe es war natürlich viel zu
testen um die fälle zu finden aber dann
auch um die kontaktperson rauszufinden
einfach wahnsinnig viele menschen
engagiert haben 1800 teams gehabt von
fünf oder mehr menschen in jedem team
die nichts anderes getan haben als zu
versuchen all die kontakte zu finden von
den infizierten und die dann sozusagen
unter quarantäne zu stellen damit
zumindest die nicht andere leute weiter
infizieren können
weil sie natürlich zeigen ist was was
natürlich total wichtig ist wir haben
mal wahnsinnig viele riesige städte
millionen städte auf der welt er sich
jetzt ist jetzt hongkong london ist auch
das was wir was wir gesehen haben am
anfang bei dem neuen kurs die leute
fliegen in die großstädte man hat die
flugverbindungen die die ausbreitung
findet erst mal zu den zu diesem großen
städten statt
und die leute tragen das virus natürlich
mit sich und verbreiten das so diese
dieser fokus auf die hände ich habe eine
der effekte dieser film hat es ja schon
dass wenn man sich diese sequenz genau
anguckt dass man danach irgendwie so ein
bisschen hypochondrisch agiert und sich
die hände ein bisschen häufiger west
wahrscheinlich wenn die tatsache dass
wir das normalerweise nicht machen also
nicht so und nicht nicht so gründlich
und uns selten klar machen wo unsere
hände eigentlich überall mit mit
irgendwie mit den händen anderer leute
in berührung kommen auch indirekt und
ich glaube dass da denken jetzt die
leute viel mehr darüber nach und dieser
film war der dicht hinter zeigt dass in
der sequenz eigentlich sehr gut trotzdem
ist natürlich so dass dass sich das
virus nicht nur über die hände
verbreitet sondern wenn man wenn man den
namen kontakt steht oder so kann das
einfach wenn man spricht über über
tröpfcheninfektion natürlich auch
übertragen werden
wir gehen momentan davon aus dass es
über die atemwege übertragen wird und
über ansteckungswege was versteht man
unter anstrengung zu hören es geht um
die übertragung durch oberflächen der
mensch gerät sein gesicht
durchschnittlich zwei bis dreitausend
mal am tag zwei bis dreitausend mal am
tag das sind zwischen drei und fünf mal
pro minute
das szenario wir sind im film
beschrieben wird es nicht das geld genau
das szenario in dem wir leben nämlich
das was die firma die die sex genannt
hat also ein erreger die mir bisher
nicht kennen und in so einer situation
ist natürlich in der regel so dass wir
am anfang keine medikamente kein
impfstoff haben das heißt alles was wir
haben ist das was wir im moment in
deutschland sehen zwei statisten singh
nicht die hand geben häufiger die hände
waschen nicht ins gesicht fassen und
dann auf der größeren ebene sozusagen
treffen vermeiden groß groß
veranstaltungen absagen
dr befürchten sie nicht dass die
sicherheitsbehörde an glaubwürdigkeit
verloren hat der überreaktion beim h1n1
virus es ist mir lieber die zeitungen
berichten von einer überreaktion als
dass viele menschen ihr leben verlieren
weil wir nicht genug getan haben darum
sind wir heute hier
das ist eine sequenz in der eine ganze
menge der der diskussion angesprochen
wird die dann immer noch alle spielen
das geht um risikokommunikation es geht
darum wie früh wie früh warnt man
tatsächlich die schweinegrippe richte
aber das ist im kopf von jedem der jetzt
sich in so einem geschehen wieder findet
es ist zwar wirklich eine pandemie
gewesen das hat sich weit verbreitet und
es gab auch viele todesfälle
aber es war unterm strich eine
grippewelle die die vergleichbar mit
einer normalen grippewelle
das ist genau das gleiche was wir jetzt
gesehen haben dann in städten wie berlin
wo dann gefragt wird geben müssen wir
wirklich die schulen schließen müssen
wir wirklich jetzt irgendwie verbieten
dass die leute auf partys gehen müssen
wir die tb absagen das sind dann alles
so sachen da spielen natürlich eine
ökonomische interessen eine rolle aber
auch ganz ganz häufig die angst der
politiker jetzt vorschnell zu reagieren
und was eine falsche entscheidung zu
treffen die nachher sozusagen als
panikmache empfunden wird und das ist
wenn man sich dann wirklich mal was
wirklich selten passiert wenn sich dann
wirklich in dem geschehen befindet wie
in dem jetzigen dann ist das natürlich
eine katastrophe weil wir einfach
exponentielles wachstum haben mike ryan
der der der chef der im menschen zu
operations bei der whu sagt dass in
jeder pressekonferenz sofort reagieren
es geht nicht darum perfekt zu reagieren
es geht darum schnell zu reagieren da
sind dann auch diese politischen
mechanismen bis hin zu zu langsam oder
zu zögerlich manchmal um in so nem
ausbruchsgeschehen also dann dann
wirklich richtig zu reagieren und ich
glaube das ist einfach so ein
lernprozess durch die leute dann
durchgehend aber es ist auch richtig
dass die politik sozusagen dann ein
bisschen bremst an manchen stellen also
das ist ein wahnsinnig schwieriges
abwägen was mir in dem jetzt bei dem
corona virus halt aufgefallen das ist
einfach dass wir die zeit komplett nicht
genutzt haben bevor das virus hier war
krankheitserreger sind irgendwie so im
kopf wir wissen dass es sie gibt das ist
keine neue gefahr sie ist irgendwie
schwerer vorstellbar da gibt es ein paar
mechanismen die dazu führen glaube ich
dass man es einfach unterschätzt und
natürlich ist das
einfach schwerer zu verstehen die menge
thesen dazu gewinne verschiedenen zahlen
aber es ist halt einfach wir werden es
wissen wenn wenn es soweit ist in
deutschland also im monat oder in zwei
monaten wissen wir natürlich viel mehr
darüber aber wir müssen jetzt die
entscheidung treffen und wir müssen
jetzt versuchen das zu verhindern
grundsätzlich diese haltung zu sagen
okay wenn wie bei überreagieren als
jetzt irgendwie in so einer situation
dass das schlimmste passieren zu lassen
das ist glaube ich am anfang erstmal die
richtige haltung die franzosen und
amerikaner haben wird eingestellt heißt
das wer weiß bescheid der amerikaner
aber unter einer decke
dass das internet das laden sie das kann
ich mich nicht daran erinnern dass das
in dem film auch schon vorkommt aber
dass das spiel natürlich in jedem aus
rocknrolla also das gab es auch immer
ich glaube was jetzt neu ist es einfach
twitter facebook bot so die art wie
schnell es sich vermeiden und auch die
art wie sich verbreitet und ich glaube
auch so dieses diese gezielten fake news
also diese sprachnachricht die in
deutschland umgegangen ist diese info
die hmi wie die whu sagt diese dieser
diesel diese flut an guten echten
informationen von hervorragenden
forschern und gleichzeitig fake news
oder einfach schlecht recherchierten
nachrichten manchmal das ist ein
wahnsinnig schweres informations
ökosystem durch das sich da auch leute
die die die sozusagen ein wenig
hintergrund da haben wenig
hintergrundwissen haben waren sich
schwierig glaube ich nur durchschlagen
können also es wahnsinnig schwierig dann
glaube ich für menschen zu wissen wo sie
genau hingehen müssen deswegen ist eine
der sachen die wir alle als
wissenschaftler ist im moment online
wahl ist ständig den leuten auch so sage
ich hier sind gute quelle das natürlich
genau das was dann in diesem punkt auch
wieder gesagt hat dann kommt natürlich
dieses misstrauen gegenüber staatlichen
stellen gegenüber allen offiziellen
stellen
da wird es dann schon sehr schwierig und
es hängt natürlich auch von der von dem
land ab und von der
von der gesellschaft struktur des landes
sie haben heute auf twitter geschrieben
dass die wahrheit über das virus der
welt von seiten des cdc und der whu
verheimlicht wurde haben sie in ihrem
blog geschrieben dass die whu mit den
pharmakonzernen irgendwie unter einer
decke steckt weil es so ist
wir wissen nicht alles wir wissen sicher
wissen wir aber dass man sich
anzustecken
um sich von angst anstecken zu lassen
reicht der kontakt mit einem gerücht
oder dem fernsehen und im internet
selbst breit gefährlicher als die
krankheit kommen die gefährliche
krankheit ist erst mal führt es dazu
dass durch die krankheit selber mehr
menschen sterben die menschen verhalten
sich da nicht so wie sie sich verhalten
sollten sie glauben nicht in den
richtlinien oder den den empfehlungen
die die von offiziellen stellen
ausgegeben werden und es gibt auch
beispiele wo zb wären sie wohl aus bous
und liberia wo dann irgendwie leuten
gesagt wurde wenn sie zwei liter
salzwasser trinken oder so dann würde
sie das irgendwie schützen und dann sind
auch leute gestorben daran also jede
menge beispiele auch von wahnsinnig
gefährlichen quacksalber ratschläge die
da die daraus gegeben werden
verschwörungstheorien gibt es gibt es in
jedem ausbruch also ich rede und
schreibe relativ wenig über die meisten
dieser sachen weil ich fürchte das führt
nur dazu dass sie sich noch weiter
verbreiten und sozusagen irgendwie als
als ernst zu nehmen so zu sagen er
hervorgehoben werden bestimmte sachen
wenn es natürlich um konkrete ratschläge
geht bestimmte medikamente zu nehmen
oder nicht zu nehmen
dann macht das vielleicht sind manchmal
darauf einzugehen pharmafirmen haben in
deutschland einfach gleich zudem den
schlechtesten ruf war von allen
industriezweigen sie immer ganz
interessant wenn man sich grundsätzlich
ja überlegt das ist ja schon so ich
meine pharmafirmen produzieren im großen
und ganzen produkte die menschenleben
retten und so wir lieben unsere
autofirmen und die produzieren im großen
und ganzen produkte die die nicht zur
genesung des planeten beitragen also ich
glaube das hat viel damit zu tun dass
das wahrgenommen wird als die verdienen
geld mit meinem leid und gerade in so
einem ausbruch
gibt es noch die möglichkeit wahnsinnig
viel geld verdienen für bestimmte leute
und ich sehe das schon dass ich es im
zelt in die großen pharmafirmen aber es
gibt schon in meiner inbox jeden tag
jetzt zehn mails von irgendeiner kleinen
firma die sagt ja wir haben hier
übrigens irgendetwas und wann sich
häufig sind das glaube ich leute die
darauf hoffen dass journalisten wie ich
dann über diese kleine firma schreiben
dann gehen die aktienkurse hoch und dann
kann man in kurzer zeit auch ein
bisschen geld damit machen
das heißt aber nicht so zu sagen dass
diese dass diese verschwörungstheorien
was diese ausbrüche angeht und so in
irgendeiner weise ernst zu nehmen sind
ich meine wenn man sich anguckt was im
moment passiert wirtschaftlich ich mein
ich glaube es wird so gut wie keine
firma geben die aus dieser situation
rauskommen wird und sagen würde das hat
sich so richtig gelohnt
die gute nachricht ist dass sie nicht
ertragen werden ok dann kann meine
tochter ist demnach auch nicht kränken
oder das kann ich ihnen nicht
versprechen aber hätten wir sehen das
nicht von mir geerbt das immunsystem
ihnen aber die andere hälfte stammt der
mutter ich glaube was menschen häufig
unterschätzen ist dass wir es halt mit
dem biologischen geschehen zu tun haben
und dass das ist nicht schwarz weiß es
gibt wahnsinnig viele infektionen die
als auch schlimme erkrankung wie cholera
oder so den großteil der menschen aber
gar nicht infiziert die menschheit als
ganzes hat einfach so viel variabilität
dann doch was das immunsystem angeht und
viele andere dinge
manche regeln sind halt gut darin
relativ breit zu wirken aber viele sind
auch nicht und wir sehen es ja auch
jetzt bei dem corona virus es gibt
machen sich viele menschen die ganz
schwache kranken offensichtlich und das
natürlich nicht nur altersabhängig hat
es gibt auch 80 jährige den milden
verlauf haben umgekehrt gibt es
natürlich auch 35 jahre ich meine lieben
young der ddr in china der gewarnt hatte
vor dem ausbruch der habe ich noch 33
oder 34 und ist gestorben aber natürlich
kann es auch menschen geben die
denen das gar nichts anhaben kann also
in den biologischen system ist
grundsätzlich immer erst mal alles
möglich aus meiner sicht müssen wir
schon das ist ein bisschen umstritten
ist immer sehr schwierig zu sagen hat
jemand jetzt einen sehr milden verlauf
gehabt also wenn jemand sagt jan
überhaupt nichts gemerkt davon oder so
hatte er dann einfach nur den verlauf
hat der mal einen leichten
muskelfaserriss überzeugende daten habe
ich noch nicht gesehen aber ich bin mir
sicher einfach bei der schieren zahl von
menschen es gibt da sind menschen weil
die wahrscheinlich so gut wie nichts
gemerkt haben davon
die frage ist halt immer infizieren die
trotzdem andere da brauchen wir noch
sehr viel daten um das sicher zu wissen
es ist mutiert in welche richtung
besserer schwimmer es hat eine gruppe
von afrikanischen aids patienten
infiziert der derben pflaster ist hoch
maria wir haben einen neuen erneuerte er
liegt nicht nur bei 22 aachen
das eine sind mutation finden natürlich
ständig statt also virus mutiert die
ganze zeit das virus mit dem es im
moment zu tun haben hat knapp 30.000
basenpaare und über die 30.000
basenpaare zwei bis vier mutationen im
monat er 24
aber natürlich wenn man sich viele
menschen infiziert werden da kommt es zu
wahnsinnig vielen veränderungen und da
können irgendwann auch mal veränderungen
bei seien die tatsächlich eine rolle
spielen also zunächst mal sind
wahnsinnig viele veränderungen so dass
sie zwar ein buchstaben dem erbgut
ändern aber letztlich nichts ändern in
den in den eiweißen die dass dieses
virus produziert eine veränderung kann
überhaupt nur dann wird in der regel und
dann relevant wenn wirklich eines dieser
dieser rezepte für ein eiweiß sich
verändert und selbst dann ist nicht
immer klar ob sich wirklich irgendetwas
an der infektiosität des virus ändern
oder an der an der schwere der
erkrankung sondern dafür muss man dann
wirklich im labor zellen infizieren am
besten sogar größere systeme infizieren
aber wie gesagt wenn sich ein virus
erbgut ändert dann kann das in beide
richtungen gehen und es gibt eigentlich
für uns keine möglichkeit das
vorherzusagen
da haben wir zum beispiel jetzt gerade
in singapur vor zwei tagen glaube ich
gar keine studie heraus die gezeigt hat
dass in singapur bei mehreren patienten
virus gefunden wurde dem ein teil des
erbguts fehlt bei saß gab es auch
relativ früh im ausbruch eine lektion in
dem gleichen
an der gleichen stelle eine kleine
revolution und da haben christian
drosten und andere damals studien
gemacht und haben im labor in der
zellkultur wirklich gezeigt dass dieses
virus sich schlechter offensichtlich
ausbreitet aber das problem ist halt im
moment das ist dann wieder zurück zur
info demi informationen im moment werden
dann öffentlich die sozusagen
interessante hinweise geben
aber die noch keine klare antwort geben
und die leute wollen aber immer gerne
klare antworten und das ist wahnsinnig
schwierig auch für mich als
wissenschaftsjournalist und sicherheit
auch für die leute die die das
kommunizieren von öffentlicher stelle
den leuten immer wieder zu sagen es tut
mir leid aber wir haben darauf keine
antwort die forschung findet im moment
eher in einer unglaublichen
geschwindigkeit statt aber trotzdem
dauert sie halt einfach und manchen
sachen dauern besonders lang
insofern davon einfach nicht müde werden
immer wieder zu sagen wir wissen es
nicht genau
selbst wenn wir jetzt einen wirksamen
impfstoff hätten müssten wir ihn hier
noch am menschen testen und das würde
wochen dauern
dann müssen wir die zulassung bekommen
und wege für die herstellung und den
vertrieb finden das dauert monate
leute die überlebt haben müssen impfen
lernt und weitere monate weitere tote
doch vielleicht im trinkwasser
beigemischt werden kann sowie fluorid um
alle auf einmal zu heilen
im stoff funktionierte erst mal
grundsätzlich nach dem prinzip okay ich
präsentiere dem immunsystem eine nicht
gefährliche kopie dieses erregers
entweder in nur 1 1 weiß was auf der
oberfläche des erregers ist oder das
ganze virus aber in abgeschwächter form
oder ein toter form und gleichzeitig
muss ich irgend etwas mitgeben was das
immunsystem stimuliert damit dass das
überhaupt erkennt als ein als ein
eindringling darum muss man in dem stoff
in der regel spritzen es gibt seit
vielen jahren forschung daran impfstoffe
oral zu verabreichendes ist für die
allermeisten impfstoffe aus vielerlei
gründen wahnsinnig schwierig
möglicherweise ist das irgendwann
möglich aber es ist auch komplett gerade
in der jetzigen situation wo sozusagen
die möglichst allen impfstoff
kommunizieren die realistischste
variante ist dass wir genau das machen
was ein bisschen machen wir machen sie
nur besonders schnell hätte vor
fünf jahren oder vor zehn jahren viel
weniger zuversicht gehabt dass wir einen
komplett neuen impfstoff in so einem
zeitrahmen von 12 bis 18 monaten oder so
produzieren können da bin ich inzwischen
viel eher zuversichtlich aber natürlich
darf man auch nie vergessen impfstoffe
ich meine es gibt krankheiten für die
wir bis heute kein impfstoff haben
und dann gibt es viele impfstoffe dieser
leicht herzustellen waren also kollege
von mir sehr viele werkstoffe
geschrieben hat sagt im impfstoff fällt
gibt es die superschweren und es gibt
die die superleichten das scheint eher
wenig in der mitte zu geben jetzt hoffen
wir alle dass das hier einer sein wird
das superleichte ist und einiges deutet
darauf hin es wird interessant sein zu
sehen in den nächsten monaten was getan
wird um die impfstoffe entwicklung
wirklich zu beschleunigen normalerweise
geht man natürlich in den tierversuch
zuerst und stellt da sicher gibt die
diskussion ob man mit manchen
impfstoffen direkt in den menschen geht
sollten diesen schritt komplett
überspringt andere sehr spannende frage
ist wird in dem clip auch deutlich ist
wenn ich jemandem impfstoff gebe das
dauert eine weile bis ich sehe ob der
wirkt oder nicht weil ich muss im grunde
genommen leuten geben und dann warten
dass sich ein teil der leute infiziert
was den etwas die impfstoffentwicklung
waren sich beschleunigen könnte wäre
wenn man menschen gezielt infizieren
könnte
das wird bei vielen
infektionskrankheiten gemacht sogar bei
malaria also eine frage die er durchaus
tödlich sein kann das nicht meine
challenge da die im englischen das wird
bei vielen erregern gemacht wenn es eine
möglichkeit geben würde das beim
menschen zu machen
mit dem corona virus das würde zeit
waren sich beschleunigen
[Musik]
ja es ist natürlich immer gleich 1 ich
möchte natürlich nicht wissen auch dass
bei einer person funktioniert und möchte
möglichst wissen ob es bei vielen
personen funktioniert vor allem davon ja
auch nicht vergessen es geht ja auch um
nebenwirkungen es geht ja auch um andere
effekte die kann ich nicht finden in
experimenten an tausend oder zehntausend
menschen
ich kann ich selbst exponenten 100.000
menschen nicht unbedingt finden die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist groß dass ich
selbst dann das nicht habe
das sind auch wieder sagen die schwer zu
kommunizieren sind und das wird mit
sicherheit irgendwann in diesem ausbruch
an den punkt kommen wo diese ganzen
themen in den vordergrund rücken aber im
moment glaube ich hoffen alle einfach
darauf dass das dass dieser impfstoff
entwicklung wirklich möglich problemlos
funktioniert die erste f1 schutzimpfung
bekommen die die an einem zehnter märz
geboren wurden zehnte ich denke dass
eine lotterie
realistisch ist das glaube ich schon
aber natürlich nicht für alle
wir sehen ja sozusagen etwas ganz
ähnliches was jetzt schon passieren wird
wahrscheinlich auch in deutschland
früher oder später was passiert wenn die
intensivstationen überlastet sind was
passiert wenn wir nicht genug
ventilation plätze haben für die schwere
erkrankung die brauchen diese
ventilation plätze manchmal wochenlang
normalerweise es gab ein stück in den
york times von drei ethikern die darüber
geschrieben haben was sollten die regeln
seien die das sozusagen die das so ein
bisschen regulieren und die haben gesagt
normalerweise würde man zum beispiel
nicht einen menschen von dem ventilation
platz runter nehmen weil jemand neues
kommt sondern dann würde man sagen okay
wir sind jetzt voll wir wandeln diese
patienten der muss woanders hingehen
oder in der situation wenn alle wenn die
rastplätze wahrscheinlich voll sind und
dann spielt es plötzlich eine rolle
dann sollten zum beispiel jüngere
menschen ihren höheres über lebensrisiko
haben unter umständen bevorzugt werden
das heißt er werde entscheidungen
darüber getroffen
wer wird leben und wer wird sterben was
auch durchaus konsens ist glaube ich war
dass leute bevorzugt werden müssten die
ärzte und krankenschwestern sind
polizisten feuerwehrmänner menschen die
zur aufrechterhaltung der öffentlichen
ordnung nötig sind
vielleicht in den entscheidenden
versorgungssystemen arbeiten wasser gas
herzlichen glückwunsch auch an arbeit
ich würde ihnen ja die hand schütteln
welche nicht mit schlechten beispiel
voran gehen
das ist wahrscheinlich die art von von
vorbild die man sich angucken würde wenn
man über den impfstoff reden würde also
da wäre es mit sicherheit auch so dass
man natürlich ärzte und
krankenschwestern die menschen die das
höchste risiko haben sich zu infizieren
und b die natürlich irgendwie
systemrelevant sind und nötig sind und
die wir brauchen um das virus zu
bekämpfen
die würden wahrscheinlich zur ersten im
stoff gedruckt dann ist die nächste
frage wir haben sich völlig
unterschiedliche risikoverteilung das
geburtsdatum würde wahrscheinlich eine
rolle spielen auch in diesem fall aber
wahrscheinlich eher in der richtung dass
man sagen würde ok je früher das
geburtsdatum umso wahrscheinlicher
kriegt man den impfstoff ich glaube nur
was im grunde genommen die größere
diskussion ist und die sehen wir auch
bereit ist die diskussion nicht wie
werden wir innerhalb deutschlands impfen
sondern wie verteilen wir einen
impfstoff der hergestellt wird global
und das ist nun fahren sie schwierige
diskussionen die natürlich in diese
ganze in die ungerechtigkeit unserer
welt und der gesetze die die ungleiche
verteilung von wohlstand und auch wie
unterschiedlich gut gesundheitssysteme
weltweit sind das spielt da alles eine
rolle
das sind halt genau die art von sachen
die natürlich in dem maße in dem der
impfstoff immer dringender wird werden
diese dinge natürlich zu nehmen und da
besteht eine riesige gefahr dass viele
länder in der welt die unter umständen
besonders schwer betroffen sein könnten
am ende das nachsehen haben und das ist
natürlich etwas wo die un die
weltgesundheitsorganisation auch
organisationen wahrscheinlich wie g7
oder g20 eine rolle werden spielen
müssen und ich hoffe dass es da in der
nächsten zeit irgendwann klare
erklärungen zu geben wird dass das egal
wo ein impfstoff hergestellt wird und
wie das ist zu einer gerechten
verteilung weltweit kommen muss aber
bisher sieht es eher nach nackt im
überlebenskampf außenministers
also in der jetzigen situation ist am
wichtigsten zum einen einfach erstmal
die krankheit ernst zu nehmen das heißt
auch diese social distance in ernst zu
nehmen auch aus rücksicht auf andere
menschen die vielleicht ein höheres
risiko haben und für einen persönlich
natürlich hygiene das heißt die hände
waschen uns gründlich waschen vielleicht
versuchen sich weniger ins gesicht zu
fassen wenn man das kann das andere ist
informiert zu bleiben die situation
entwickelt sich wahnsinnig schnell und
auch die forschung schreitet waren sich
schnell voran und wenn man da informiert
bleibt dann hilft das glaube ich und da
gibt es zb twitter hervorragende leute
den man folgen kann denen ich auch folge
um informiert zu bleiben und die könnt
ihr hier finden
danke kupferschmid dass du dir zeit
genommen hast dieses interview mit mir
zu machen danke schön dass du den film
noch mal angesehen hast ansonsten war
das noch nicht alles wir haben den film
auch zwei experten vom max planck
institut für bildungsforschung gezeigt
die beiden befassen sich eher mit der
reaktion der gesellschaft auf das virus
also angst panik und risikokompetenz und
was diese beiden experten zu sagen haben
das führen durch hier im zweiten teil
auf dem kanal der max planck
gesellschaft ansehen
ansonsten würde mich jetzt mal
interessieren wie ist dieses video hier
bei euch angekommen sollte ich häufiger
mal so wissenschafts interviews machen
schreibt mir das gerne in die kommentare
oder beantwortet eine umfrage hier oben
ansonsten immer bleibt neugierig dank
fürs zuschauen und bis zum nächsten mal